but first is my brain dump
there's a test for you try reading this
headline out loud without feeling like
you've landed on another planet
stella creasy jk rowling is wrong women
can have a penis
then there's this one
from stella creasy's labour mp colleague
annelise dodds
solid crazy is wrong a woman can't have
a penis
and finally this one
labour mps at war over whether a woman
could be born with a penis
well my apologies for repeatedly using
the p word but it's rather significant
here when you're talking about women
because i wasn't aware that they had one
we've got to this ridiculously absurd
stage of magenta debate a civil war
erupting between two british female mps
from the same labour party
over something that we already all know
the answer to but who can blame them for
their confusion when their own leader
sakir stama can't even answer the
question at all
a woman can have a penis
nick i'm not
i don't think we can conduct this
debate with
you know
sorry i'll get this
he's not asking you for pythagoras's
theorem
he's just saying
what's a woman
can a woman have a penis this is also
insane
a woman is an adult female who does not
have a penis i can't even believe i have
to say that on air
this is not something that should be
debated
it's a biological fact you can't refute
basic scientific sexual physiology
i mean you can scream and you can bully
and try to cancel people
but ultimately facts are facts science
is science
now gender is a different matter
in a free society you can identify
frankly as whatever you please that
doesn't mean the rest of us have to buy
into it or that society has to change
all the rules to suit your latest
identity whim and fancy like the debate
over what a woman is gender
self-identity is also going completely
bonkers
british police forces are now allowing
suspects to choose from 67 genders
i mean imagine being the guy sorry woman
sorry person who has to make the bar
charts for crime statistics
meanwhile prison officers are told to
use whatever personal pronouns inmates
decide they want to be called
and not to be outworked the british
civil service is ordering workers to
recognize a hundred genders
while also paying them to attend gender
neutral book clubs and celebrate
non-binary awareness week
by the way
of those hundred genders they include
the following omnigender
pangender
two-spirit
demigender
grey gender
gender void and my favorite gender
outlaw
the love of god the only void is between
the ears of the people who come up with
this nonsense the only thing needs to be
outlawed is this time-wasting absurdist
nonsense at the heart of our government
i support respect and protect trans
rights always have done but women mps
insisting that women have penises and
authorities officially recognizing
gender outlaws as a gender
there's nothing but damage those rights
by making a cruel mockery of trans
people who actually go through the long
difficult process of transitioning and
it's got to stop
well almost a week on from the horrific
texas school massacre there's no sign of
any consensus in the embittered debate
over gun rights but as more grim details
emerge is a rare agreement developing
about one thing the gutless valley
police
failed these children
we now know that 19 armed police
officers were inside rob elementary
school during the 78 minutes
the shooter salvador ramos unleashed his
hellish murderous rampage that's one
officer for each of the children who
were killed
eight desperate calls eight were made at
9-1-1
by kids inside the classroom on their
cell phones before the police finally
went in
it's better than i read it than you
listened to it
identified herself and whispered she's
in room 112.
at 12 10
she called back
in room 12 adviser multiple dead
at approximately 12 43 and 12 47 she
asked 911 to please send the police now
at 12 46
she said she could not see that she
could hear the police next door
at 12 50 shots are fired they can be
heard with a 911 call and 1251 is very
loud and sounds like the officers are
moving children out of the room
isn't this unbelievable
kids in the classroom
who'd seen some of their fellow students
being murdered
were calling 9-1-1 to tell the police
who was standing outside with guns what
was going on
and for minute after minute after minute
those police did nothing
until it was all too late
we've been told that they were waiting
for keys for tactical equipment for
orders from their boss
we're also told in their apparent
defense that apparently they could have
been shot at and killed well yes they
could but that's actually their duty
it's literally what they signed up for
to protect the public
after the columbine high school massacre
in 1999 where 13 people were shot dead
as police waited outside for an hour
cops were ordered after that to
prioritize the safety of people under
threat not themselves
police in ivaldi were briefed on this as
recently as march they were specifically
told
officers first priority is to move in
and confront the
attacker but they didn't
not one of those armed police chose to
confront the shooter before it was too
late
as a result of their shocking collective
cowardice
19 children and two teachers are now
dead
shame on them
we'll bring out the bunting ready the
victoria sponge cover everything in the
union flag
it's almost platinum jubilee street
party season
but no not if the fun police have their
way
15 million brits are preparing to
celebrate 70 years of the queen's reign
this weekend with a mammoth
four-day traditional best of british
street party but killjoy councils are
reportedly warning the six weeks notice
is required for a road closure so the
multitude of neighborhoods you missed or
didn't even know about the deadline will
be holding street parties which are now
going to be deemed illegal
they're quite literally replacing our
bunting with red tape when did the land
of hope and glory become a land of nope
and boring
come on
we've had dismal summers of life under
covet lockdowns unable to hug our loved
ones and where finger food was frankly
unthinkable
this is the perfect time for a massive
party
a rare moment of national unity in
respect of our greatest and
longest-serving monarch
once again
i turn to my late great friend cricket
legend shane warne for the best response
to party pooping claptrap
and in this politically correct day and
age we've just got to be a little bit
careful but sometimes just say get stuff
to the fun police
exactly my message to the british people
is ignore these pen pushing jobs worth
get out there and celebrate our queen
like you've never done before
i regret to say i have a trigger warning
[Music]
the following clip contains scenes of
unbridled masculinity
you will never forgive yourself
no turning back now
come on
having any fun yet
i know wokies i know all that raging
testosterone
it's all so toxic isn't it problematic
primitive
arrestable even
well it's also turned out to be
staggeringly popular yes the
long-awaited sequel to top gun has
racked up box office sales of more than
248 million dollars in this opening
weekend smashing post pandemic records
and easily becoming the biggest hit of
tom cruise's already stellar hollywood
career how can this have happened after
all it's a jet fuel bullseye supersonic
rampage in which cockshaw guys drink
fight disobey orders ride motorbikes
without helmets bond over fixing engines
bottle up their feelings bail out their
mates play macho topless beach
volleyball get the hot girls and kill
all the bad guys
and even bravely sticks two fingers over
china by refusing to remove the taiwan
flag from mavericks jacket
this is a movie for people like me who
regularly moan they don't make movies
like that anymore when i watch the great
man celebrating films of the 70s and the
80s and we're loving it i took two of my
sons to see top gun maverick on friday
it was the best escapist fun i've had at
the movies since 1986 when i was 21 and
i went to see the first top gun movie at
the cinema 10 times in three weeks
the main reason i loved it because i
came out feeling better than i went in
what was that the last time i had a
cinema
and i also felt proud to be a man
of masculinity rather than ashamed of it
as the feminazis constantly want us to
feel don't get me wrong some men are
awful but spoiler alert so are some
women
and some forms of masculinity are toxic
undeniably
but maverick reminds us as the box
office sales prove that sometimes good
old-fashioned non-toxic chest beating
masculinity is just what everybody wants
and needs